LAURENCE MORONEY: Today
on Coffee with a Googler
we're having coffee, cloud,
containers and a whole lot
more with stand up comic
and developer advocate
extraordinaire Carter Morgan.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, Carter, you've had so many
roles like soldier, bartender,
I hear you worked in
a software company
over in Redmond, blogger.
What brings you to Google, and
what are you doing here now?
CARTER MORGAN: Well, I
came because I wanted
to be a developer advocate.
I wanted to stop being
a software engineer,
where I was at the other
company in Redmond and what not.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I know the one.
CARTER MORGAN: You know one?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
I think that's it.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
And so I wrote this nine page
cover letter to try and get in,
because I'm like, you have
no experience in this field.
Somehow they let me in.
And now I get to run
workshops and teach people
how to use our
technology with videos,
or workshops, blog posts.
It's really cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
A nine page letter?
CARTER MORGAN: I did.
It was literally nine pages.
It was all Google
colored and themed.
It was horrible looking.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Do
you still have it?
CARTER MORGAN: I do.
I still look at it time to time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
framed in your office?
CARTER MORGAN: So
I wanted attention.
I didn't have any
experience in this role,
so I did things like I wrote
a haiku in the middle falsely
attributed to Rob Pike.
It said something
like, you don't
have to write long cover
letters if your name is
Rob Pike, signed Rob Pike,
or something like that.
And someone that I interviewed
with sent it to him,
and I get this response back,
and it said something like,
ad hominem arguments for
[? and or ?] [? khand ?] are
not convincing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And that's a haiku.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah,
and I didn't realize it.
I just thought Rob
Pike was really mean
and just dashed my dreams.
LAURENCE MORONEY: He's not mean.
He's way above average.
Sorry, that's my bad
joke for the day.
So I'm the one making
the joke, but you also
do stand up comedy right?
CARTER MORGAN: I dabble.
I try and do some stand up,
mostly in Seattle and whatnot.
It's been a real big help
for the job and speaking
in front of people.
Well, I don't have
to be afraid anymore,
because I've been in
front of drunk audiences.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, just given
that you've done
the stand up comedy,
and you weren't a
developer advocate before,
and you wrote this big
letter, and that brought you
into Google, how was it to fit
into the role of a developer
advocate?
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
when I first joined,
I joined the DP team.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so DP are
the people who build our sample
applications right?
CARTER MORGAN: Yes, so
developer of programs engineers.
And they are more
internal facing.
And developer advocates are
more customer-developer facing.
And it wasn't a good fit.
It was a year that was
really a tough fit, because I
wrote this nine page cover
letter like, here's all
the external stuff that
I do, and they're like,
don't do that.
But Google was really flexible,
and they kind of worked with me
to transition to this team.
So it's still
finding your place,
how can I be most effective.
You get a lot of freedom
in this role, which is--
it can be terrifying when
you join a new company
with all these smart people.
Rob Pike works here.
You work here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'd lower the average
to balance it out with Rob.
So that's the only
reason they hired me.
So you're doing all this
stuff like outreach,
that kind of thing.
Now, it's cloud that you
work on and Kubernetes
in particular right?
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
So the tool I've been focused
on for the first year I
was at Google was Kubernetes,
and that's, basically,
an orchestrator for containers
or running applications,
so how do you do that at scale.
Now that we've done
that for a year,
I'm moving over into continuous
integration and delivery,
which is how do you
actually deliver a software,
how do you send updates
out in a controlled manner,
a deterministic way.
And so the tool we're focusing
on right now is Spinnaker.
So that's been exciting,
too, because, again, it's
like every year
it's almost like you
have to start from
scratch and relearn
a whole tool, or
platform, or community.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
And that's also what it's
like for developers, right?
With the pace of
technology going so fast,
there's continuing pressure on
them to keep their skills up
to date.
So people like you and me, our
job is to get ahead of that,
and to be ready to
teach them, and to be
ready to share our experiences.
One of the nice things is
that you're not a salesperson.
CARTER MORGAN: I'm
not a salesperson,
and so that's really important.
There's got to be some
times where I say,
I don't think this
tool is the best.
I don't think this is
the right way to do it.
And I think that's something
a salesperson couldn't say.
They'd have to be like, use
this product no matter what.
It's the best.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You don't have
a quota to meet or anything.
You love this
technology, and you
get to share it with people.
CARTER MORGAN: 100.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, I know
you have a new video series,
the "Cloud Rolling Update."
Could you tell us about it?
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
So the "Cloud Rolling
Update" is a series
where we show why Google
Cloud Platform is the place
to deliver code to and from.
And so the first
couple of videos
are brief overviews of this
tool called Google Container
Builder.
It's like a Docker tool, but
you don't use it locally.
You use it in the cloud.
It's really cool.
And then after that,
we're going to talk
about Spinnaker and continuous
integration delivery
using Kubernetes.
So the idea is you have
an application, well,
how do you update it?
And we're going to show how
to do that on Google Container
Engine.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now,
I know you've brought
a clip of the show with us.
What's this clip?
CARTER MORGAN: So this
clip is the first video
in the series, where you
probably get started,
and it's just covering
Container Builder, so what
is it, how do I use it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
let's check it out.
CARTER MORGAN: And on
top of that, it's fast.
It has support for
custom build steps,
which can be concurrently.
And there's support for
using build triggers,
so that you can create
images automatically.
And all of this comes
with full integration
with Google Container Registry,
the same service that's
being used by Google Cloud
Functions, App Engine
Flex, and more.
So let's see this in action.
For example, if you
already have a Docker file,
you can just use it
like you normally would
to build a container image.
Here, you can see we have
a standard Docker file.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
In that video, you
were talking about
Container Builder.
So if I'm a developer,
and there's just
this array of options
in front of me,
what's a good way for me to
get started with this stuff
to take advantage of it?
CARTER MORGAN: Well, the
first thing I would do
is check out the link
in the description.
We've got tutorials and videos
showing how to use the tool,
and why you want to.
That's first.
So Container Builder just
replaces, on the cloud side,
tools that are common to
most developers like Docker.
So now instead of having
to run it locally,
you can just send
that out to the cloud
and it'll run for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So in addition to
all that, I know
you've done teaching through
things like Udacity courses.
CARTER MORGAN: You have, too, yeah?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I have, and
they're really fun, because--
has your experience
been the same as mine?
That whenever you go to an
event, and you're talking,
there's usually somebody
that goes, I know that face.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
Sometimes I've had
the opposite, too.
So I did this course
with Kelsey Hightower.
He's super popular.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We all know Kelsey.
We've had him on the show.
He's great.
So we want to have
him on the show again.
So just tell him we said that.
CARTER MORGAN: I'll tell him.
But so, I was at a conference,
and someone came up to me,
and they're like, hey,
have you seen Kelsey?
And I'm like, no, not yet.
Is there anything
I could pass along?
And this person
goes, yeah, I just
wanted to tell him that
the course was great.
And I'm like, I
was in the course.
But no, normally,
a lot of people
come and they say
thank you for teaching.
They really like the
guided progression
through a topic and
the really short videos
instead of this long overview.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because
it's hard to sit and watch
45 minutes on cloud.
I love cloud, but it's
hard to sit and watch
45 minutes on cloud.
But three or four
minutes of you,
three or four minutes of Kelsey,
and then and little a quiz
afterwards, that kind of thing,
it also helps retain knowledge.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
So, again, you're
changing up the nods
that's coming, the presenter,
and so it's always engaging.
And so I think that's
the most important thing
to think about, whether you're
writing a sample or an article,
is how can I engage
people, how can I
write this in a way that makes
them want to reach the end
and don't feel overwhelmed
to get started.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So we spoke
a little about the Udacity
course, and I just realized
for a lot of people
out there who don't understand
what Kubernetes is, it's
really cool, but what is it?
CARTER MORGAN: I should
have started there.
Kubernetes is a
container orchestrator.
So a container is just a way
to bundle an application.
So you can run it anywhere, and
it's going to behave the same.
That works really
well on one machine,
but when you scale up to 10
machines, 100 machines, 1,000,
it doesn't scale as well.
And so what you
want is something
to manage all that
complexity for you.
How does container A
talk to container B?
What happens if container
B gets shut down?
Do I want to manually go to a
terminal and start it back up,
check if it's up?
No.
And so Kubernetes is
a container framework
that sits on top of something
like Google Container
Builder or Docker and
runs these containers,
starts and stops them, makes
sure they're communicating,
helps check so much
more all for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
I want to get started
by putting together an
infrastructure that uses that,
where would I go?
CARTER MORGAN: Well, we
have the Udacity course,
which is free three hours of
training from myself and Kelsey
Hightower.
There's kubernetes.io,
which is a great start.
Probably more links
in the description.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, sounds good.
Now, you've mentioned
Kelsey Hightower.
You get to work
with some superstars
here on Google, right?
CARTER MORGAN: I do.
That's probably my favorite
part about being at Google,
to be honest.
One, I get to work with people
that are really intelligent.
Part of the "Cloud
Rolling Update" series
is taking things I've learned
from other people like Vic
Iglesias, Ahmet Balkan,
Kelsey Hightower,
and putting that
into video format
for a different audience.
I've also gotten a
lot of mentorship
from people like Kelsey,
Sarah Novotny, Colt McAnlis.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow,
some good names there.
CARTER MORGAN:
Yeah, and it's cool
because they've been so open.
These are people
that are established
at a company like
Google, and they're still
taking the time to say, hey,
let me show you the ropes.
Let me help you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So when you
wrote that nine page letter,
was that what you felt
would end up happening?
CARTER MORGAN: You
know, I had no idea.
I had no idea.
I'd never been to a
company like Google,
like such a young
and open company.
And so I'm still learning
how to be a good Googler.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
got to blog that letter.
We all want to see it now.
CARTER MORGAN: I have it
if you want to see it.
It's on Medium.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
yeah, if it's on Medium,
I'll look out for it.
CARTER MORGAN: I'll
send it your way.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks,
we'll put it in the links.
One of the things
that we've seen,
even with people we've been
talking to on this show,
is that just 18 months
or two years ago,
cloud was always that thing
that seemed to be in the future.
But now it's like it's
almost the new normal, right?
That if I'm a developer
starting out today,
it should be cloud first.
It should be let's
get going, right now.
And is there any
advice that you give
to developers starting out?
CARTER MORGAN: So the best
thing that happened to me was,
again, someone told me to learn
this Kubernetes framework.
And the reason why is it
abstracted away all the
behind the scenes.
I didn't have to think
about machines anymore.
So I learned one API that had
years of Google's experience
behind it, and then I could
manipulate objects at scale.
So that was really
useful for me.
And so, now, some
people look at me,
and they say, oh, I'm an expert.
And I'm like, no I got lucky.
I learned the right tool first.
So for me, I would
start off with learning
how to manipulate
or use Kubernetes
and then using that
to think about how
I think about distributed
applications or cloud based
applications.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you're able
to do programming at your desk,
but expand that to cloud
scale and to Google scale
in the cloud, which
is just phenomenal.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
So it's crazy, because
with Kubernetes you
can say something
like, Kubernetes run,
and it creates some
application instance for it.
Then you can say,
Kubernetes scale that up.
Kubernetes expose that
so I can talk to it.
And all the behind the scenes,
the networking, the scheduling,
all that's taken care of.
If you were starting from
scratch maybe two years ago,
you would have had to do
that yourself, all the steps.
And so there's a lot of
power in these platforms
or these frameworks
that abstract away
all the underlying mechanics of
working with cloud programming.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you've gone
from a guy writing a nine page
letter to try to get
into Google into one
of the foremost recognized
experts in cloud at Google.
Great cloud series,
teaching stuff on Udacity,
and it's just been
a privilege to be
able to chat with you today.
So thank you so much, Carter.
For everybody else
who's watching,
we've put the links in
the description below.
Carter's video course
is a must watch.
And if you want to
learn about cloud,
and you want to learn
about Kubernetes,
check out his Udacity
course as well.
So thanks so much, Carter.
CARTER MORGAN: Thanks, Laurence.